مرحبا يا صديقي كيف حالك؟
مرحبا بك الحمدلله لكن
آآآه آآه لست بخير،
خيرا يا عزيز ماذا بك؟
ولم كل هذا التأوه؟
ألا ترى وضع العالم اليوم،
وكأن الأحداث تجري باتجاه
حرب لا تبقي ولا تذر،
وأمريكا تحاول لملمة القضية لكن
تعنت الروس يحول دون ذلك،
وأين هم حلفاء أمريكا من هذه القضية؟
في العقدين الماضيين كانت الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية هي من يسيطر على الوضع
في العالم بأسره،
وتسير كل القضايا عبرها،
أما اليوم فهي لا تستطيع إيقاف التضخم
في أسعار الغذاء في أراضيها فضلا
عن أن توقفه في دول العالم،
وبعض حلفاء أمريكا الأقوياء يتعرضون
لضغط غير مسبوق،
فأوكرانيا توشك على السقوط بيد روسيا!
ومجنون كوريا يهدد اليابان!
والصين ستجتاح تايوان!
وشبه جزيرة العرب تعيش الفوضى بذاتها!،
والخليجيون لم أصبحوا لا يفرقون
بين حليف وعدو!!.. وتقول لي ماذا بي!!،،
إن لم أجن قريبا فتلك معجزة!!!
.
ما هذا الذي يجري يا ترى؟ هل انتهت وصاية
أمريكا على العالم، وأصبح حلفاؤها
يتساقطون كأوراق الخريف؟
أليس هذا حكما متسرعا يا صديقي
فالحروب لا تنتهي إلا بانتهاء آخر طلقة للمتحاربين،
كما لا تنتهي مباراة كرة القدم إلا بصافرة الحكم،
أتدري يا صديقي أن روسيا تستطيع
حسم المعركة خلال أيام قليلة لا تتعدى
عدد أصابع اليد الواحدة؟
ومن قال لك ذلك، ألا ترى القوات الروسية
تراوح مكانها من غير تقدم ملموس
خصوصا في العاصمة كييف؟
الذين يبذلون قصارى جهدهم لإسقاطها
لكن هيهات أن يحصلوا على العاصمة!
إنني أرى وأرى بوضوح لكن لماذا
لا ترى أنت ويرى الغرب سقوط أوكرانيا الوشيك؟
لماذا لا ترون ما يحدث على أرض الواقع؟
من؟ نحن؟
نحن نرى الدعم الذي تحظى به أوكرانيا فقط،
لكن ألا ترون أنتم ذلك؟
ما الذي تتحدث عنه يا صديقي؟
وعن أي دعم تتحدث؟
دعم الغرب وأمريكا وكذلك حلفاء أمريكا
من الدول في العالم،
وأنت لا شك تعرف كم هم حلفاء أمريكا في العالم!
لقد أوهموك كما أوهموا أوكرانيا
بأنهم لن يتركوا روسيا تمسها بسوء،
هل تعرف مثلا عربيا يقول
(نطق الغراب وقال خيرا وأين الخير من وجه الغراب)
ربما لو حذفنا حرف الألف من كلمتي
الغراب في المثل لفهمت قصدي؟
أنت ما الذي تقوله ألا تعلم أن أمريكا
هي أقوى دولة في العالم وتمتلك
أقوى جيش في العالم؟
وأنت ألا تعلم أن روسيا تتبادل مع أمريكا
مكانة أقوى جيش في العالم بين حين وآخر،
بل وتقول بعض التقارير أن روسيا
هي الأقوى في العالم وتمتلك أقوى جيوش العالم،
وسأضيف أنا لذلك شيئا واحدا،
نحن نعلم أن من يمتلك أقوى سلاح في الوقت الحاضر
هو الأقوى بطبيعة الحال،
وأقوى الأسلحة حاليا هي أسلحة الدمار الشامل
وعلى رأسها تأتي الرؤوس النووية،
حيث تمتلك روسيا أكثر من ٦آلاف
رأس نووي بينما تمتلك أمريكا ٥آلاف،
إننا نتحدث عن قرابة ألف رأس نووية
لروسيا أكثر من أمريكا،،
فهل عرفت الآن من الأقوى؟
يبدو أنك تتوهم
فلو لم تستطع أمريكا حل أمر روسيا بنفسها
فلها الكثير من الحلفاء علنا،
بينما يخشى حلفاء روسيا التصريح بتحالفهم،
كي أجيب عليك سأطرح سؤالا واحدا،
ألا تعلم أن أوكرانيا هي أكبر دولة في أوروبا؟
هذا إن افترضنا جدلا أن الاتحاد الأوروبي
قد قبل انضمام أوكرانيا إليه،
أوكرانيا هذه التي هي الأكبر مساحة في أوروبا
وقع معظمها تحت سيطرة الجيش الروسي،
أضف إلى ذلك أن مساحة قارة أوروبا
بأجمعها لا تتعدى نصف مساحة روسيا
إلا بشيء بسيط جدا، هل فهمت الآن؟
حسنا! لقد قلتها بنفسك!
إذاً لماذا لم تستطع روسيا العظمى
التي تحدثت عنها أنها الأقوى في العالم
أن تسيطر على أوكرانيا وقد بلغت حربها
شهرا كاملا دون جدوى؟
ومن قال لك أنها دون جدوى
روسيا تسيطر على أوكرانيا في الجو والبحر
وتكاد تسيطر على البر لكن هناك شيء واحد
يعيق تقدم قواتها، وهم المدنيون،
ألا ترى تصريحات الكرملين؟
الدب الروسي يريد أن يبسط سيطرته
على كامل الأراضي الأوكرانية نعم!
ولكن ليس على حساب المدنيين،
فلو قرر الكرملين استخدام قوته أكثر قليلا
فسيكون هناك الكثير من الضحايا
من النساء والأطفال والعجائز،
وهو ما تتجنبه قوات روسيا..
حسنا يا صديقي! حسنا!
أنت تقول أن روسيا لم تستخدم كامل قوتها
فكم تبلغ قوتها التي تتحدث عنها يا ترى؟
ألم يكفي أن ذكرت لك ٦آلاف رأس نووي،
إذا فلتضف عندك التالي
لدى روسيا أقوى قنبلة صنعها البشر
(قنبلة القيصر الروسي)
وسلاح الشمس الحارقة أو الأرض المحروقة،
وصاروخ سارمات أو ما يسمى
بالشيطان الأكبر، وغواصات بوسيدون المسيرة
النووية،، أيكفي هذا أم تريد معرفة الذي تقدر
على فعله هذه الأسلحة؟
لا لا! يكفي ربما أنت تتحدث عن قوة عظمى
لكنها لن تستطيع تجاوز الدعم الذي تحظى به
كييف من أمريكا والغرب،
نعم هنالك دعم غربي أمريكي لا يتوقف،
لكن ألا ترى أن سيطرة قوات موسكو
على المدن الأوكرانية تعني بالضرورة
السيطرة على الدعم الغربي، من أسلحة وذخائر
وغيرها من الدعم العسكري،
وآخرها حين أعلن الكرملين السيطرة
على صواريخ جافلين الأمريكية،،
بينما تعلن وزارة الدفاع الروسية دائما
تدمير الطائرات المسيرة ومنها طائرات تركيا
البيرقدار التي تتباهون بها،  فماذا تريد أكثر؟
دعك من هذا الهراء،
الحرب تقترب من حدود بعض دول
حلف الناتو والحلف
(الذي يعد أقوى تحالف عسكري دفاعي في العالم)
يهدد روسيا بأنه سيرد على أي ضرر
قد يمس دولة عضوا في الحلف،
فما الذي ستفعله موسكو حيال ذلك؟
نعم قد تصل الحرب إلى أماكن لا تريد
موسكو إيصالها إليها، لكن ما هو واضح،
أن هذا الحلف يصرح دائما أنه لن يدخل
حربا مع روسيا أبدا، وكذلك تعلن أمريكا
أنها لن تدخل حربا ضد روسيا أيضا،
ألا يعد هذا تصريحا بالخوف من موسكو؟
وماذا عن أوكرانيا هل سيتركها الغرب لمصيرها
بعد أن أطلقوا وعودا وأخلفوها؟.
روسيا تقول للغرب نحن هنا
في أوكرانيا فأين أنتم؟
الغرب وأمريكا متواجدون في كل مكان
في العالم لكنهم يخافون من اندلاع
حرب عالمية ثالثة إذا ما تدخلوا في أوكرانيا،
إذا كانت قوات العالم تخاف روسيا
إذا فلماذا نتناقش هنا فأوكرانيا ستسقط لا محالة
وسيعد ذلك سقوط لقوات العالم هذه
التي تتحدث عنها،
(ولتضع ذلك في بالك مستقبلا)
روسيا لوحدها ترعب العالم فمن يستطيع
مواجهة الدب الروسي؟
ومن قال لك أن روسيا لوحدها،
فهي تمتلك تحالف قويا أيضا،
فلديها الصين وكوريا الشمالية وإيران أيضا،
وهو تحالف يهدد تحالف الغرب كذلك،
إذا فليست روسيا لوحدها..
تمهل ي صديقي أولم تتحدث سابقا
أن حلفاء روسيا يخشون الغرب
ولا يستطيعون حتى إعلان تحالفهم
صراحة مع موسكو؟
نعم قلت ذلك لأن الصين كانت تعلن حيادها،
لكنها مؤخرا قد أطلقت تصريحات غريبة،،
حيث أدانت دعم أمريكا العسكري لأوكرانيا
والذي يفترض أن يكون دعما إنسانيا بحسب بكين،
كما حذرت الصين حلف الناتو من التوسع شرقا،
وهذا يعني بداية إعلان لانضمام الصين
إلى جانب روسيا،،
وإن كنت تتحدث عن كوريا الشمالية
فهناك زعيم مجنون لا يُعرف ماذا يفعل
ومتى سيفعل، وهو بالتأكيد لن يترك حليفته روسيا..
أما إيران الدولة النووية فهي حليف دائما
لروسيا وانظر إلى آخر اللقاءات بينهما ...
إذا فلتبتعد يا صديقي عن القلق والتوتر
فالغرب لن يجرؤ على قتال روسيا وحلفائها،
وروسيا لن تقوم بقتال الغرب ما لم تُجبر على ذلك،،
وفي كل الأحوال ربما يكون تضخم الأسعار
للمواد الغذائية والنفط والغاز
هو تضخم مؤقت،
وسينتهي عقب أن تحل روسيا أزمتها مع أوكرانيا،
فلا دعي للقلق..
وسأراك لاحقا لنرى ما الذي حدث
مما تحدثنا به هنا وما الذي لم يحدث!!